bonjour je suis étudiante et je cherche
un job étudiant est-ce que par hasard
vous embaucherez
une petite question je suis étudiante et
je cherche un job étudiant est-ce que
d'accord bon ça marche d'accord ok ça va
ok d'accord ça marche
hello à l'école
des bouchers un deuxième job étudiant
parce que j'en ai déjà un mais ça suffit
pas parce qu'en fait par moi il me
manque 500 €, donc c'est un gouffre
clairement qui qui s'offre à moi
aujourd'hui il faut juste traverser la
rue et on trouvera du travail
moi la rue je la traversée tous les
jours et c'est un mur littéralement un
mur que je veux je suis étudiante et je
cherche un job étudiant est-ce que
d'accord
je vais m'arrêter là je vais arrêter de
vous y allez c'est ce sera la bonne
cette fois-ci
malheureusement d'accord
ça dépend des moments mais là aller vers
les gens comme ça je suis là allez
courage ça ira bonjour je suis étudiante
et je cherche un job étudiant est-ce que
par hasard vous embaucher
si il y a pas d'offres d'emploi sur le
site c'est que il cherche pas et qu'ils
vont jamais regarder ces candidatures
ça se voit que je cherche de l'argent en
fait
parce que par hasard vous embaucherez
il y a personne c'est faux ou alors je
peux être que je plais vraiment pas mais
bonjour j'avais une petite question
monsieur je suis étudiante et je cherche
un job étudiant est-ce que par hasard
ok d'accord ça marche merci au revoir
j'ai faim et voir toute cette nourriture
là
[Musique]
ça sent vachement bonjour j'avais une
petite question je suis étudiante et
cherche un job étudiant est-ce que par
hasard je peux vous laisser un CV
on est à temps partiel et ça leur plaît
pas en fait
bonjour j'ai une petite question je suis
étudiante et je cherche un job étudiant
est-ce que par hasard vous envoie alors
nous le souci c'est qu'on a déjà nos
petites étudiants d'accord et à chaque
fois que j'ai ça je suis là allez
continue t'arrête pas parce que souvent
j'ai envie de rentrer chez moi juste de
faire le déni l'autruche quoi et je peux
pas plus on avance ensemble moi je suis
donc ouais il faut un travail assez
rapidement que je puisse avoir ma paye
très très vite et combler le vide quoi
une minute de mon école et 5 minutes de
la garde c'est vraiment très correct
pour tout ce qui est autre dépense j'ai
à peu près 60 euros d'Internet par mois
10 € pour ma musique oui c'est pas
essentiel mais moi j'aime bien
travailler
EDF enfin l'électricité j'ai à peu près
60 euros par mois 160 euros de courses
ouais on va dire par mois ça dépend ça
varie
même si une fois je voudrais manger
c'est juste pas possible c'est beaucoup
trop cher
résultat des courses 54 euros pour deux
sacs
les prix on vachement monté en plus je
calcule tout genre dès que j'ai mes
courses tout le temps j'ai ma
calculatrice à la main donc on peut pas
dire que je fais pas attention quoi
c'est vraiment
ça augmente dans les revenus fixes j'ai
200 euros d'une bourse
de Secours populaire et 104 du coup s'il
te plaît j'ai 40 euros bah là pour mon
petit job à la vapeur 40-50 ça varie je
route pour aller à la vapeur donc c'est
une salle de concert assez réputée à du
jour travail jusqu'à 22h15 peut-être
trois quatre fois dans le mois maximum
le programme il est trop bien j'adore
j'accepte à plein de concerts je suis à
la billetterie donc il y a plein de gens
c'est juste extraordinaire là à peu près
par mois il doit me manquer autour des
500 euros j'ai pas encore nouvelle des
aPL je les ai demandé j'espère que la
simulation de 200 euros sera sera juste
parce que sinon ça va faire un petit peu
recrac
souvent quand je fais des Togo c'est là
et ils sont trop assez nappy ou qui
ressentent par exemple les magasins en
fin de journée au lieu de jeter ils vont
créer un panier en fait et pour moitié
prix nous on va l'acheter et voilà
récupérer les soirs et on a plein de
trucs on sait jamais à l'avance qu'on a
c'est des paniers surprise et par
exemple bah là on aura descendu des
petites pâtisserie des trucs comme ça
donc une fois pour 3 euros j'ai récupéré
6 baguettes et deux pains enfin c'est un
truc de malade c'était trop bien
et voilà après ouais il est pas il est
pas fourni fourni c'est un miracle que
j'ai des œufs parce que généralement je
ne mange pas là c'est pas moi
je me serais pas permis ça sinon j'ai ma
petite astuce c'est que je congèle
énormément de pain et en fait je vais
découvrir un morceau et genre je le sors
je sors tous les matins enfin la veille
je le dis et hop j'ai mon petit bout de
pain voilà c'est pratique j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup d'étudiants
ont un sentiment de honte vis-à-vis de
la situation financière je sais pas par
exemple juste ils osent pas forcément
aller dans les endroits on peut trouver
la nourriture gratuit au début j'en ai
aussi honte alors je comprends j'en
avais aussi honte vraiment honte je sais
pas aller voir les gens je me suis dit
mince mais ça se trouve proche pas assez
dans la galère enfin des choses comme ça
et aujourd'hui j'en ai plus honte qui
galère très clairement voilà et c'est
pas grave c'est comme ça je peux pas
forcément demander de l'argent à mes
parents comme ça tout le temps parce que
bah ils sont enfin ils ont aussi leurs
dépenses ils ont ma petite sœur ils sont
agriculteurs donc ça varie aussi en
fonction des récoltes et en fait on leur
demandant pas d'argent finalement j'ai
l'impression d'être beaucoup plus
responsable je suis vraiment autonome
enfin j'aime pas compter sur les gens je
préfère compter sur moi-même je suis
vraiment bosseuse enfin j'ai pas peur de
me salir les mains ou travailler de 6h à
minuit c'est quoi
[Musique]
des asperges travail saisonniers analysé
serial ensuite je travaille pour le
théâtre de Beaune je suis des serveuse
ou des événements émérite Beaune après
j'ai fait l'inspection des cultures de
maïs donc cet été donc je marchais à peu
près
20 km par jour en plein soleil j'ai été
conseillère mutualiste en septembre j'ai
aussi fait les vendanges en plus les
weekends et là maintenant je n'ai pas
encore noté je suis vacataire du coup
elle a vapeur donc voilà c'est plutôt
bien remplie du coup là il est midi j'ai
eu une petite pause repas et je vais en
profiter pour aller déposer les CV et
donc ça c'est ton rituel un peu tous les
jours quoi bah ouais c'est ça tous les
matins je voulais midi quand j'ai un peu
de temps
c'est les job étudiants n'hésitez pas à
venir dès le mois de juillet je sais
plus j'étais pas sur Dijon moi donc je
suis arrivée qu'en septembre c'est assez
compliqué je faisais un peu en ligne
mais c'était galère
ok merci bonne journée au revoir
je pense très bien travailler dans la
grande restauration enfin je veux dire
la restauration rapide de façon etc mais
eux leur heure de pointe c'est entre 19h
et 21h puisque moi je suis encore à
l'école à ce moment-là je peux pas
débarquer à 20h coucou je travaille une
demi-heure et c'est fini quoi souvent
quand je dis non en fait je vais pas
sortir et tout j'ai pas sous mon violon
je t'invite
de voir d'argent à quelqu'un ou qu'on
paye des trucs c'est mes amis c'est pas
c'est pas mes porte-monnaies en fait
parce que par hasard vous embaucherez
malheureusement d'accord
ça prend une place dessus commentaire
mais sur la planète ok d'accord
ça marche parfait merci bonne soirée
merci au revoir je te l'avais dit
bonjour
j'ai une petite question je suis
étudiante et je cherche un job étudiant
est-ce que par hasard
par mois ok ça fait 24 heures par
semaine ok ouais
la semaine ça dépend comment ça 9h45 le
matin ouais non bon
bah merci beaucoup au revoir je donne
mon maximum à chaque fois je suis là
j'ai vraiment envie d'aller dormir mais
j'ai encore distribué des CV aujourd'hui
j'ai encore fait le tour des mêmes
enseignes ça n'a rien donné du tout en
fait c'est une fatigue
et ouais une fatigue psychologique un
peu c'est enfin émotionnel voilà pas
psychologique émotionnel c'est juste
j'en ai marre chaque fois elle me disent
non ou après je me dis ça se trouve j'ai
pas assez distribué de CV aujourd'hui ou
j'aurais dû faire des boutiques en
priorité j'ai pas eu le temps puis là je
devrais faire si je devais faire comme
ça donc ça absorbe mais littéralement
s'absorbe tout mon énergie quoi
l'énergie que je devrais mettre dans mes
cours en fait je la mets pour ma
recherche de job et c'est pas normal
bah là du coup ouais j'étais en cours et
on a fini un peu plus tôt donc je vais
direct foncé chez moi récupérer mon CV
et je suis parti quoi c'est beaucoup
plus simple
et j'en profite encore pendant que les
magasins sont ouverts
on a beaucoup des CV là déjà mais on
sait jamais ouais ok d'accord ça marche
merci beaucoup bonne journée au revoir
elle était adorable ça se voyait dans
ses yeux que c'était c'était mort quoi
mais souvent c'est je suis désolé mais
vraiment désolé je suis pas grave j'ai
trouvé pas de problème bonjour j'avais
une question je suis étudiante et je
cherche un job étudiant est-ce que par
hasard vous embaucherez
ok d'accord merci
bonjour excusez-moi
c'est le marathon de ouf en plus les
gens ça les énerve tu vois que je passe
comme ça du coup sur la Wii vous le
savez c'est bon déposez le
je cherche un job étudiant est-ce que
par hasard vous embauche c'est un CV
mais ok d'accord merci
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir j'ai une petite question je suis
étudiante je cherche un job étudiant par
hasard vous embaucherez
aussi
merci bonne soirée au revoir et adorable
elle est trop gentille
du coup j'ai laissé combien de semaines
à deux ou trois je crois ouais
j'ai reçu un appel pour pour un travail
du coup ce serait de baby-sitter
répétiteur je crois que c'est tous les
samedis matin
donc voilà ça peut être vachement sympa
et puis bah je vous tiendrai au courant
hello bonne nouvelle de la journée fin
de la soirée ce qui est 19h30 j'ai eu le
job je l'ai eu je suis sauvée
mais vraiment waouh ça soulagement du
coup ce sera tous les samedis matin et
c'est vachement chouette je suis trop
trop contente voilà c'est trop bien